[Música]
pasando de tema Las y los atletas
transgénero han condenado la exclusión
de las competencias femeninas de élite
por parte de World athletics para
mujeres transgénero que antes del cambio
atravesaron la pubertad masculina una
decisión que llegó la semana pasada y
que otras atletas femeninas celebraron
como justa aquí en Francia 24 hemos
tratado este tema en varias
oportunidades y hemos dado voz a las
mujeres trans afectadas y que se
consideran en situación de
discriminación esta vez queremos también
hacer un balance con un concepto
biológico que nos permita entender
argumentos y extender la discusión con
el respeto por el otro para ello vamos a
conversar con Lina Jaime quien es
especialista en medicina del deporte
ejercicio y de la actividad física y
también está en el estudio de directo
América nuestra periodista deportiva
eumaré esa Así que bienvenida Lina
Gracias por estar en directo a América
muchas gracias a ustedes mucho gusto
quiero empezar preguntándole Por qué la
clave de la decisión de Word athletics
es el paso por la pubertad masculina
Cuál es la diferencia de que hace Este
paso Sí realmente Precisamente es la
pubertad que nos marca las dos grandes
diferencias si bien nosotros Digamos
como mujeres u hombres tenemos cierto
influjo hormonal desde que estamos
básicamente en el vientre materno hay
una la pubertad es donde más producción
de hormonas sexuales en este caso
hombres y mujeres la testosterona
cambian básicamente La diferencia son de
10 a 20 veces la concentración entre
hombres y mujeres y es aquí en este
punto donde el desarrollo tanto del
sistema muscular que intervienen
tendones ligamentos y el tipo de músculo
el tipo de fibras que se desarrollan
cambian y son diferentes entre hombres y
mujeres no solamente eso la
la longitud de las extremidades también
el sistema cardiopulmonar el hematocrito
que Precisamente es esa cantidad entre
digamos para explicarlo así de
hemoglobina que nos ayuda nos ayuda a
transportar sangre y la cantidad de
eritrocitos que hay todo esto en
conjunto va a llevar a un mayor
rendimiento entonces por eso es tan
distinto este esta transición de género
antes o después de la pubertad no es lo
mismo haber tenido un desarrollo
muscular con testosterona o con la
concentración de testosterona de un
digamos un nombre un de género masculino
que una transición con la testosterona
la concentración de un Pues de la mujer
saludos para empezar y le preguntamos la
hormonación es un elemento clave dentro
de todo este debate qué tanto afectan
las hormonas el rendimiento deportivo y
es factible seguir una propuesta que
hizo recientemente un atleta trans en el
sentido de establecer categorías de
acuerdo con la concentración de
testosterona
Claro que sí de hecho El Punto de
partida o realmente la base entre todo
para que una mujer o para que un
transgénero pueda no competir digamos
con mujeres es precisamente la
concentración de testosterona endógena
que es el marcador principal para
precisamente esta ventaja deportiva ya
está más que demostrado que Precisamente
hay una ventaja respecto a las mujeres
trans con respecto a las mujeres si bien
en este momento ya se habla que hay
cierto cierto número de años se habla
que entre dos a tres años como mínimo
puede disminuir esta ventaja hormonal
esta esta ventaja heredada como se le
llama entre mujeres trans y mujeres
digamos que biológicas Por decirlo así
vemos Que si hay una ventaja y que
realmente los estudios que hay ahorita
sobre todo en nadadores sí Hay una
ventaja
de tiempos entre las mujeres trans y
mujeres
biológicas
que le quería preguntar porque el
referente anterior al del atletismo es
el de la natación con el caso de Lía
Thomas que primero compitió como hombre
después hizo la transición y compitió
como mujer y esto pues provocó que
pasara de ser digamos un competidor
regular a una gran competidora muy
destacada y esto fue lo que desató las
regulaciones y posteriores prohibiciones
en la natación entonces
habría que pensar esto también por
deportes porque no se puede generalizar
el mismo uso de fuerza o el mismo dese
físico en cada disciplina Exacto
totalmente de hecho esto incluye
solamente deportes que están basados en
el en el rendimiento cardiopulmonar aquí
excluimos ajedrez deportes electrónicos
tiro esos días se pueden excluir
solamente en deportes que nos digamos
que se basen en el rendimiento
cardiopulmonar como natación atletismo y
para responder a la pregunta anterior
también digamos que la propuesta que
hacen respecto a las concentraciones
hormonales estaría bien porque Digamos
si hay cambios sin embargo hay que tener
en cuenta y muy O sea hay que tener en
cuenta y Resaltar que como este como
este tema es nuevo
básicamente yo creo que en los últimos
10 años ha dado mucha fuerza faltan
bastantes estudios Sí hasta ahora
estamos haciendo esto Entonces sí es
importante que digamos que si se hablen
como estudios preliminares y lo que se
ha visto pero definitivamente si sea una
diferencia en esto y hay que también
mejorar O aproximar de una mejor manera
estos tratamientos
precisamente de reafirmación de género
No usted se refería a un periodo de que
iría de uno a tres años en los cuales
los atletas trans permanecerían fuera de
competencias siguiendo el proceso de
hormonación eso no implica que pierdan
el mejor momento de su edad competitiva
en algunos deportes depende del deporte
porque eso depende de deportes y estamos
hablando de temprana especialización
como digamos la gimnasia
la natación o de ya más digamos que
especialización menos temprana o más
tardía como el tenis u otros deportes
digamos en este caso los deportistas
Pueden seguir entrenando pero si es por
decirlo así que es la discusión que
ahorita que no sería justo precisamente
con las mujeres o las mujeres biológicas
la competición de estas personas en este
tiempo
se habla más o menos de dos a tres años
sin embargo hay en algunos estudios en
algunas más bien en algunas discusiones
se habla de un año pero un año es
demasiado poco para ya disminuir esa
ventaja
heredada que se tiene esa ventaja
hormonal que ya se tuvo más aún si fue
durante después después de la pubertad
pues viene Lina Jaime especialista en
medicina deportiva gracias a usted por
sus apreciaciones y bueno también
tendríamos que evaluar ella fuera del
estudio porque se nos acaba el tiempo si
es realista hacer un cambio en las
reglas deportivas porque también hay que
pensar en las legislaciones de los
países no que en muchos casos no
permiten que se haga la transición antes
de los 16 años por ejemplo y Esto
evidentemente va a afectar a los y las
jóvenes atletas yo les agradezco a las
dos y también nos quedamos con la
conclusión de que al final va a ser una
repetitivo pero no hay nada concluyente
no faltan muchos más estudios y este es
un debate que continúa gracias a
nuestros televidentes sigan en directo
América pequeña pausa y ya volvemos
[Música]